lo que pasa en el salvador no queda en
el salvador en una frase así podría
resumirse como la comunidad
internacional ha percibido que el
parlamento centroamericano bajo las
riendas del oficialismo destituyera el
sábado al fiscal general del país y a
magistrados de la sala constitucional de
la corte suprema una primera acción
parlamentaria que no sólo ha sido
tildada de ataque al estado de derecho
sino que hace ruido por tratarse de
funcionarios hostiles al presidente en
allí bukele del lado europeo la
inquietud la expresión el representante
joseph murray sobre la independencia
judicial siguiendo con preocupación los
últimos eventos en el salvador que
cuestionan el funcionamiento del estado
de derecho y la separación de poderes
mientras que la vicepresidenta
estadounidense kamala harris en la misma
línea de la onu pidió cuidar la
constitución nacional nos preocupa
profundamente la democracia del salvador
un poder judicial independiente es
fundamental para una democracia sana y
para una economía fuerte pensando sólo
en esta economía más de 20
organizaciones civiles temen una posible
crisis más allá de la institucional una
crisis que no solo la misma sala la
declaró inconstitucional al no tener el
debido proceso
sino que podría agudizarse ya que lo que
le ha evocado a otros despidos aquí nos
costó 30 años votar el régimen que nos
tenía en la miseria en la corrupción en
la inseguridad y en la desesperanza
negociaba con la vida del pueblo y
ordenaba asesinatos desde las
instituciones hay vídeos de eso el
pueblo no nos mandó a negociar se van se
van todos en el mismo tweet el
mandatario apelando a nicaragua y
honduras solicitó a la comunidad no
intervenir en sus asuntos internos